hello my name is wendy adams i'm an
assistant laboratory director
at nms labs in pennsylvania i'm talking
to you today about the new relevance of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
in forensic toxicology first i'd like to
disclose that i am a paid employee of
nms labs
a commercial provider of toxicology and
other forensic testing services
i have no conflicts of interest to
disclose
so i thought this topic would be of
interest to forensic toxicologists and
perhaps
other forensic scientists because
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine have
been featured in the news recently
beginning in early march on the 4th of
march
chloroquine was added to covid19
treatment guidelines in china
based on multi-center clinical trials
however they did note in the clinical
trial publication that chloroquine
should not be used in patients with
heart disease
quickly after that the world health
organization included chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine in
international solidarity clinical trial
to treat
covid19 the following day
president trump referred to
hydroxychloroquine as a game changer
in the fight against the covid 19
pandemic
shortly after that the food and drug
administration authorized emergency use
of chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine
for the treatment of covid19
following all of this there have been
reports of
toxicity related to these two compounds
on april 9th the american association of
poison control centers
issued a statement that
hydroxychloroquine exposures had doubled
compared to the same two-week period in
2019
from a total of 35 to 76
and also on march 22nd it was reported
that a couple in arizona
drank chloroquine phosphate algaecide
that they had mixed with juice
in an effort to prevent symptoms and
onset of covid19
following the ingestion they were both
sickened and hospitalized
one of the patients died from cardiac
effects
in the interest of talking about these
drugs
in a context of forensic toxicology
by discussing their adverse effects
followed by beneficial effects
of course they are two sides of the same
coin i'm starting with the adverse
effects
because that's the most important part
to toxicology
i'll also speak briefly about
pharmacokinetic concerns
for interpreting blood and other body
fluid concentrations
and some risk factors for toxicity
so to get started with the good the bad
and the ugly effects
let's talk about the mechanism of action
of this class of drugs
it begins with quinine a substance that
was
extracted from sinchona bark
in peru and it was used in india and sri
lanka by the british empire as a tonic
to prevent malaria
it was a very economical treatment it's
also the bitter agent that's added to
tonic water
there are two other molecules used as
drugs
based on this same four amino quinoline
structure
as quinine there are chloroquine which
came first
and hydroxychloroquine adding a hydroxyl
group
to the chloroquine molecule
i called this slide the law of
unintended consequences
these drugs have diverse mechanisms of
action
they act on many different sites inside
of the cell and the body
and because of that they can have a
variety of different effects
both good and bad so first of all
there's the structural similarity to the
prostaglandins and cytokines
which allow these molecules to inhibit
the enzymes in the inflammatory cascade
they're also charged molecules and this
feature allows them to accumulate in
lysosomes
which is particularly important to their
treatment of malaria
they also inhibit endosomes that are
involved in transport in the cell
and this feature is also the reason that
they bind to melanin which will become
important when we talk about retinopathy
as a side effect a third mechanism of
action
is their ability to block the pore of
potassium channels
and the picture at the bottom of the
slide shows the hydroxychloroquine
molecule docked inside
of an inwardly rectifying potassium
channel
so it effectively plugs that hole and
prevents potassium from passing through
finally hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine
both act as zinc ionophores so they can
shepherd
zinc molecules within the cell zinc is
an important
component of rna replication
and the ionophore feature allows these
molecules to
inhibit rna replication so of course
this would slow the
division replication of the virus
this is a summary of the different
mechanisms of action
and how they are both visible for
adverse effects and beneficial effects
so first being the synthesis if you
inhibit prostaglandin synthesis
you can cause immunosuppression which
might not be a good thing
if you system emotions
however this also has a beneficial
effect anti-inflammatory
and this is the reason inhibiting
prostaglandin synthesis
is inhibiting thromboxane which is
primarily involved in clotting so
hydroxychloroquine has
anticoagulant functions
the second mechanism the increased ph of
lysosomes
contributes to the adverse effect of
retinopathy
in this case it inhibits transporters in
the retinal pigment epithelium
and it accumulates in the eye and can
cause
death of those cells however
it's also a beneficial effect because
this is what gives it its ability to
fight malaria
and also because it stops transport
across cell membranes
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine have
both been investigated
to be combined with chemotherapeutics
because they help to
reduce resistance that cancer cells have
by
ejecting the chemotherapeutics from
inside the cell the third mechanism of
action
blocking potassium channels seems to
contribute to the cardiac toxicity
of these drugs including contributing to
hypokalemia
as well as arrhythmia finally
the zinc ionophore disrupts
right so the beneficial effect of that
is that these drugs can act as
antivirals
however cause edge to rapidly
tissue that needs similar zinc finger
domains in order to replicate
dna and that can be effects seen
primarily in the
gi tract gastrointestinal tract as well
as bone marrow
i'm going to talk in detail about each
of the adverse effects of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
first cardiovascular effects
the main feature of hydroxychloroquine
and chloroquine is that they can
increase the qt interval this is thought
to be mediated by the hypokalemia that
they cause
the longer qt interval
can contribute to arrhythmias and
increase risk of rhythmic mortality
second blood dyscrasias
this is unknown adverse
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine as
well
because of the zinc ionophore that
impairs rna and dna replication
and can cause bone marrow failure
some different blood dyscrasias reported
after using these compounds include a
plastic anemia
a granulocytosis leukopenia and
thrombocytopenia
it's particularly important to note that
individuals who already have a genetic
disposition towards a plastic anemia
with
glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase
deficiency
are contraindicated for using
hydrochloroquine and chloroquine
first effect is retinopathy and more
effects have also been
seen with hearing loss and bleaching of
hair
because hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine bind to melanin
they're likely to interact and sequester
with melanin containing tissues
including the choroid of the eye they
cause damage to these cells
usually around the macula which can
cause irreversible blindness
they induce vacuole formation through
their lysosomal
eh altering ability and that results in
cell lysis and retinal death
for this reason a maximum dosage of five
milligrams per kilogram daily
has been recommended for
hydroxychloroquine
next are adverse effects in the central
nervous system
these drugs have been shown to lower the
seizure threshold
the mechanism is not well characterized
however it does appear to be related to
inhibition of gabaergic signals
and gabaergic is the primary depressant
in the central nervous system so
inhibition of gabaergic
neurotransmission
would tend to be excitatory thus
contributing to the risk of seizures
other additional adverse effects in the
central nervous system can include
dizziness taxia muscular weakness and
tremors
also psychiatric adverse effects include
nervousness
irritability and psychosis mares
and even suicidal behavior
among the adverse effects of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
are multiple drugs
so there are interactions
different drugs you use to treat heart
disease
important to note amiodarone
an increased risk of arrhythmia if
hydroxychloroquine is combined with
amiodarone
as well as with any other drug that
could lengthen the qt interval
while increased plasma cyclosporine
levels were reported
when hydrochlor hydroxychloroquine was
co-administered
the tendency for hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine to
cause hypoglycemia could mean a dose
adjustment is warranted
for insulin or other hypoglycemic drugs
and finally there are different effects
of acids on chloroquine concentrations
so they might not be able to be taken
together
here are some details about hypoglycemia
that's caused by hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine
it's rarely severe but it has been
reported even in non-diabetic patients
ethanol consumption is a risk factor for
this type of hypoglycemia
the drugs inhibit insulin metabolism
which causes increased
concentrations of insulin in the blood
and before
promoted glucose transport into the
cells
overall the blood concentration of
glucose is depleted
and the brain experiences this as
hypoglycemia
which can cause dizziness and weakness
there's also a beneficial effect though
because
diabetic patients will actually have
improved glycemic control
while they're taking these drugs
there are four main risk factors for
toxicity
the first are individuals with glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase deficiency
of hemolytic anemia the second are
patients with liver disease
caution should be used in patients with
hepatic disease alcoholism or
hepatotoxic
drugs and this is primarily due to
combined
toxic effects on the liver
such as cardiomyopathy epilepsy and
diabetes
we'll need careful consideration when
using hydroxyl
and chloroquine and there are some age
groups that are particularly vulnerable
to these drugs
for example chloroquine has been shown
to cause birth defects
in animals infants and children
are noted to be extremely sensitive to
the toxic effects of all four amino acid
alums
and geriatric patients may have impaired
excretion due to reduced renal function
now the other side of the coin so any
substance that produces
active effects whether they be adverse
or beneficial
can also prove produce the opposite side
of the coin
the beneficial effects also have a
variety of
mechanisms that they use targeting
lysosomes being the original
and older mechanism of action
four amino quinolones accumulate in
lysosomes becoming charged in the acidic
environment
and this prevents them from diffusing
out so they accumulate in that lysosome
change the ph of it and can cause
swelling or
malfunction of the organ
this makes them toxic to plasmodium
parasites
which is a great benefit for treating
malaria
they also inhibit notable enzyme
function including the mhc class ii
antigen presentation on monocytes
because they selectively inhibit
presentation of
self antigens they're very useful for
the treatment of autoimmune
in particular systemic lupus
erythematosus
cysts is also a mechanism of action
related to antiviral properties
of hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
because they increase the ph of
lysosomes they inhibit viral entry
into the cell viruses need to move
from the early endosomes abbreviated
eea1
until late endosomal lysosomal protein
abbreviated lamp 1
in order to be released into the cell
and this step
is ph dependent i have a graph from a
recent publication
showing untreated cells chloroquine
treated cells
and hydroxychloroquine treated cells and
where
viral proteins were localized within the
endosomes
you can see that chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine
held viral proteins inside of early
endosomes and prevented them from
reaching
late endosomes this would also help to
prevent their infection of cells
some additional actions of
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine
they enhance zinc uptake into cells
which helps to interfere with rna
polymerase
they can also inhibit glycosyl
transferase enzymes
and it's glycosylated ace2 receptors
that are the anti
site for severe acute respiratory
coronaviruses
and finally they inhibit the clotting
cascade
and platelet aggregation which is
beneficial in patients with covid19
because they can have hypercoagulation
as a late manifestation of the disease
now some words about pharmacokinetics i
have each
drug on its own slide hydroxychloroquine
is first
for absorption it's well absorbed with
70 to 80 percent
bioavailability following oral dosing
it's distributed very widely throughout
the body with a large volume of
distribution of 47 000 liters
this is because it can bind to cellular
components of blood
including platelets and can also
concentrate in tissues
such as the liver lungs and other organs
it is metabolized primarily by sip2d6
to the active metabolite des ethyl
hydroxychloroquine
and has a very long elimination
half-life 537 hours in blood
which is the same as 22 days
and the active metabolite is an even
longer half-life of 40 to 50 days
these compounds can both remain
detectable in urine for months after
treatment is stopped
chloroquine has similar pharmacokinetics
to hydroxychloroquine
89 bioavailability
plasma protein binding of 60
an even larger volume of distribution at
65 000 liters
it's metabolized also by sip enzymes but
different ones in this case
3a45 and 2c8
and has two active metabolites does
ethyl chloroquine
and bi-diethylchloroquine
the half-life of elimination increases
with dose
and two examples are following 250
milligram dose
three hours but following a thousand
milligram dose
300 hours or 13 days
again detectable in urine for months
because of these properties the large
volume of distribution in particular
pre-analytical factors are a concern in
the analysis of hydroxychloroquine
and chloroquine keep in mind that the
mechanism of these drugs includes being
sequestered in red blood cells
chloroquine can also absorb to glass so
it should be collected and stored in
plastic
and because of this tendency to
sequester in red blood cells
the blood concentrations tend to be
higher than those in serum
you can also get irregular serum
recovery depending on how
long you clot the sample and what speed
you centrifuge it at
so it can be more straightforward to
interpret blood reference ranges
if they're not collected by the same
study parameters as the reference range
the blood to plasma ratio is also high
at five to ten
postmortem blood concentrations in
non-toxic cases
overlap the concentrations reported in
fatal cases
that's not uncommon for drugs with a
large volume of distribution
and it makes it difficult to use a final
postmortem concentration
to interpret whether a dose was toxic or
not
it may be due to postmortem
redistribution of these compounds
so just note to interpret postmortem
concentrations with caution
for specimen handling these compounds
are both
remarkably stable at room temperature in
a variety of fluids
it's also possible to analyze
chloroquine as a dried blood spot
and that can be kept at room temperature
for 1.2
years with desiccant and maintain
a similar concentration as when it was
originally collected
analytical techniques are reported
in a great variety and abundance since
these drugs have been around for
many decades lcms
has two references here and you can see
the measured range usually starts
close to 10 or 20 nanograms per
milliliter
most of these methods are in whole blood
and one of them in capillary blood
for sampling smaller volumes this is
again because it's easier to interpret
concentrations in the whole blood matrix
since you don't have to account for the
variability of recovery following
clotting
there's also a method called turbulent
flow
lcms that's used for
whole blood analysis and two different
screening techniques
gcms a mainstay of forensic toxicology
and lc tof time of flight mass
spectrometry
chloroquine being older and perhaps not
as commonly encountered
today by forensic toxicologists does
have some publications even in
recent literature an lcms method for
analyzing
whole blood plasma and dried blood spots
a similar lower limit of quantitation to
what we saw for hydroxychloroquine
about 10 or perhaps slightly lower than
that nanograms per
ml in blood spectrofluorometry was also
used
in the 1970s gcnpd
can be used as a technique for
quantitation
and lc time of flight mass spectrometry
is also effective at screening for
chloroquine
if you happen to identify these
compounds through screening and are able
to get a concentration
it can be interpreted with caution
against published reference ranges
it might not be likely to detect them
with general unknown panels however so
you might need to look at case history
to determine which samples should be
sent for quantitative analysis
the concentrations for therapeutic use
of these compounds are both similar
200 nanogram per ml is the average
concentration in responding
rheumatoid arthritis to patients
chloroquine
and 200 is the cut off for non-adherence
in lupus patients
both of them have a therapeutic range
around 400 to 500 nanogram per ml
but note that the therapeutic ranges for
chloroquine are being reported in
theorem in this case
so they could be very different in blood
hydroxychloroquine concentrations are
reported in blood
and high therapeutic concentrations
tend to be about two to three times
higher than those
average concentrations with therapeutic
use
in non-fatal overdose hydroxychloroquine
concentrations as high as 26 000
nanogram per ml in serum have been
reported
that case did require resuscitation and
involved a 36-hour coma
post-mortem non-toxic and overdose
ranges
were also reported and you can see the
overlap there where
non-toxic concentrations can be as high
as 39 000 nanograms per ml in blood
while post-mortem overdose can be as low
as 20 000.
similar thing is seen for chloroquine
with postmortem non-toxic as high as 14
000 nanogram per ml and overdose
starting as low as 3 thousand
this is actually recommended by one
publication to use
liver for interpreting chloroquine
postmortem
150 milligram per kilogram was
established as a threshold for overdose
in summary hydroxychloroquine and
chloroquine have diverse mechanisms
and may cause a spectrum of adverse
effects these can include
cardiac arrhythmia retinopathy
lowered seizure threshold and blood
dyscrasias
medical conditions as well and drug
interactions increase the risk of
adverse effects
these can include glucose 6-phosphate
deficiency drugs that increase the qt
interval such as digoxin
drug interactions infants and children
are also known to be more sensitive to
toxic effects
and finally blood or plasma should be
collected
in plastic tubes and compared to a
matching reference range
or normalized with the blood to plasma
ratio in mind
and consider liver concentration for
postmortem interpretation
in my last slide i have included several
resources for further information
there are many different drug
interaction checkers on
the internet some examples are here
the benefit of the interaction checker
is that you can enter
multiple drugs that are found in a case
and see if they interact with each other
to cause side effects
for example entering azithromycin with
hydroxychloroquine
will give you an indication of a
moderate interaction
because both drugs can extend the qt
interval
making them arrhythmic
some government resources include daily
med
which is a great way to search for full
prescribing information using either the
brand or generic name of a drug
the drug information portal is very
useful
if you're uncertain of the spelling of a
drug so it might have been
transcribed incorrectly by somebody at a
crime scene
and you can put in a misspelled drug
name and
the drug information portal will give
you a list of the best matches
it also links to daily med
the clinicaltrials.gov page includes
international trials
as well as u.s trials at the moment
there are 79 active studies
for hydroxychloroquine including the
keyword
treatment of covid and finally
fda that is a
great site to go to for history of drug
approvals and
current status you can also subscribe
there to updates for recalls and safety
alerts
that's the end of my presentation i
thank you for your time and i hope you
enjoy your education experience at lab
roots